après 11 heures de délibération le jury
est parvenu à un verdict et c'est en
silence que les trois hommes accusés du
meurtre d'un mot d'ordre ils ont écouté
le juge travis mahatma cause son père
greg et leurs voisins william brown sont
reconnus coupables de 24 des 27 chefs
d'accusation dont celui de meurtre mais
nous le juré dit le juge trouvons chavez
mcmichael coupable de meurtre c'est lui
qui a ouvert le feu après une
altercation avec le jeune afro-américain
qui faisait du jogging dans le quartier
les trois hommes pour chasser en voiture
le jeune homme affirmant qu'il avait
pris pour un cambrioleur qui rôdait dans
voisinage tous les trois ont été
reconnus coupable et risque la prison à
vie
dit son nom ahmed ammori scande la foule
à l'extérieur du tribunal sa mort avait
provoqué des manifestations anti
racistes durant l'été 2020
d'autant plus que les trois hommes
avaient été arrêtés près de trois mois
après le drame seulement lorsque des
images du meurtre filmé par l'un d'entre
eux avait été diffusé
le poing levé main dans la main avec les
parents de la victime
les ténors des droits civiques aux etats
unis ont salué le verdict john white and
black edition il faut que le monde sache
qu'un jury de 11 blanc et un noir dit-il
dans le sud des états unis s'est tenu
debout pour dire que la vie des noirs
comptent les avocats de la défense irons
en appel tout en reconnaissant que le
système judiciaire fonctionne bien
c'est décevant et triste dit-il mais
nous comprenons que c'est une journée de
célébration pour la famille
pour lé fmi abri le deuil peut enfin
commencer à nefta de style car
bagdad
je ne pensais pas que cette journée
arriverait dit sa mère merci pour vos
prières coise et le surnom dame d'anjou
tél il pourra maintenant reposer en paix
il ya ces bordelais guerguisse
radio-canada washington